let's talk about anxiety and how to turn
off anxiety like a switch now the term
anxiety comes from the Latin word which
means to strangle now that makes sense
if someone's trying to strangle you
you're gonna feel anxiety right I
remember about I don't know probably
twenty eight years ago sitting in an
audience okay
on a stage and there was a speaker and
the speaker asked me to come up and
speak now there was no preparation I had
a fear of public speaking and so I was a
little bit forced to come up there and
speak and I was devastated when he
mentioned my name and so everyone's
clapping yes go up there so I get up in
pure terror
and as I'm walking to the stage my
throat starts closing up my mouth gets
dry I get dizzy I walk up on the stage
and I look out and I'm completely about
ready to pass out I can't even speak I
was in the state of terror in fact I had
the fear of public speaking so bad in
college I was this close to dropping out
because we had to do a speech in front
of class so it was a big fear so I said
that's it I have to overcome this fear
so I went back to my practice and I
started doing seminars just small groups
with a slideshow that I use with this
little projector where I had these
little slides I don't know if you
remember those little slides that you
put in the projectors now it's all
digital so I would go through the
slideshow in the dark
sitting down okay so that way they
couldn't see how nervous I was so then I
built up to turning the light on but for
those seminars I would actually bring
alcohol like champagne and cookies that
was way before keto and that way they
would actually laugh at my stupid jokes
and then I progressed and I started
doing more seminars and more seminars
and after about 4,900 seminars in a row
I no longer had the fear of public
speaking so that was my little side now
about my anxiety okay
flight-or-fight this is the book that
I'm going to show you
it's called autonomic nerves okay it's a
fascinating book and this book is all
about the autonomic nervous system which
is composed of the sympathetic nervous
system which is the flutter fight I'm
going to read something to you
what is the flight or flight reaction
the flutter flight reaction is a
physiological response to a real or
perceived threat to one's safety
depending on the nature of the threat
the person either mounts a defense fight
or attempts to escape from a threat
flight runaway right both
fight-or-flight require sudden vigorous
muscle action the body prepares itself
for action in the following ways and
it's right here you'll start having a
racing heart the blood flow goes to the
muscles start sweating shaking throat
constricted breathing changes blurry
dizzy you feel nauseous irritation worry
which is the feeling that something bad
is gonna happen poor concentration mine
goes blank
that's what happened to me in front of
all those people you focus on the
negative right now on the positive and
one of the problems with being in a
chronic state of flight-or-fight is it
screws up your sleep then you're tired
and then your memory goes okay and then
you lose your focus and you're just not
productive at work it can really affect
a person on many different levels now
over the years in practice I've noticed
some really interesting things about
certain people that have anxiety the
diet is nearly always not right okay
they're usually consuming things that
are stimulants that are they're
depleting them of certain nutritional
factors especially vitamin b1 and by the
way if you have anxiety you need to be
taking lots of b1 you will notice relief
within three to four minutes after
taking b1 in fact you should probably
get all the B vitamins as well and make
sure that they're natural not synthetic
I recommend doing nutritional yeast that
provides the best quality
so the B vitamins are one of the most
important things to counter this okay
now probiotics now your microbes
actually make B vitamins they make a lot
of b1 b2 b3 b5 b6 b12 also folic acid
biotin they make a lot of different
nutrients and not only that they make
amino acids that then can be turned into
neurotransmitters like gaba dopamine
noradrenaline serotonin melatonin all of
these neurotransmitters that help you
feel calm help you sleep at night so if
you have any problem with your gut let's
say you have some damage in your gut
your silly AK or you've taken
antibiotics before and you just don't
have all the flora or you consume foods
like regular normal foods that are GMO
which by the way to destroy the microbes
that block the ability to make this now
if you think about the problem with GMOs
you have this chemical called glyphosate
glyphosate destroys certain mechanisms
that make amino acids in insects and
microbes but apparently they say it
doesn't affect humans but guess what you
have microbes that make a lot of
nutrition and actually make proteins so
when you consume GMO foods you're
interfering with the flora the gut
microbes which are indirectly going to
affect these and the microbes that make
B vitamins causing you to end up being
deficient in certain factors and then
now your moods going to start to kind of
go south after that also artificial
sweeteners can have a negative effect on
your microbes in your gut one of the
best ways to get probiotics is through
fermented foods like sauerkraut or other
similar fermented type foods and then we
have magnesium magnesium is a really
good mineral to help calm the adrenals
down and counter anxiety very very
important and I would take magnesium in
higher amount
if you have anxiety also you want to
avoid the environmental triggers so you
know there's certain things in your
environment you have people you have
your work you also have what you watch
on TV on the internet you just want to
make sure that you're not constantly
reminded of things that stress you and
this is why watching the news is very
bad with people with anxiety so reverse
that get outside take long walks
exercise get lots of oxygen adaptogens
are herbal products that really will
help to increase the tolerance to stress
so you can actually deal with things a
lot better if you want more information
about this I put a link down below check
it out all right well thanks for
watching and before you go if you
haven't seen my video on the stress
webinar that's a really important one
that watch it's quite long but I put it
right here check it out when you have
some time
you